[Applause]
literally no one had more fun at the MTV
VMAs than Taylor Swift it's been amazing
loving it after slaying the red carpet
the singer made her way inside taking
home her first award in no time
presented by NSync
[Applause]
yeah Taylor totally fangirls over the
boy band reunion as they presented her
with the moon person for best pop video
you guys are you're you're pop
personified so to to receive this from
your golden pop hands is
really
it's it's too much and amid rumors of an
in-sync anniversary tour or special
performance Tay took the opportunity to
ask Justin Timberlake JC Chasez Lance
Bass Joey Fatone and Chris Kirkpatrick
the burning question on everyone's mind
like are you doing something what's
gonna happen now what are you there's
something they're gonna they're gonna do
something and I need to know what it is
like I don't understand how you cannot
fan girl about that and when she landed
the prize for a song of the year she
seemed just as Star Struck by presenters
Nelly Furtado and Timberland who have
collaborated over the years most notably
on 2006's promiscuous
I miss you again
[Music]
something right oh my God
Taylor sat next to her karma remix
partner ice spice and at one point she
took over the rapper's insta story POV
you're in front of ice spice at the VMAs
oh she just looks like that all the time
all the angles all the angles I'm dying
then Tay's bestie Selena Gomez won best
afrobeats alongside remma for their
track calmed down something Taylor
couldn't do as she watched sell on stage
I should say something you know I want
you I want you to come on
Tay worked up a sweat dancing to all the
performances
she cheered on her peers in the crowd
and went viral after her drink got stuck
in the cup holder safe to say Taylor had
a great time taking home nine Awards by
the end of the night including video of
the Year artist of the year and album of
the year it's just a lot of a lot so
let's hear it for Taylor the reigning
Queen of the VMAs
[Music]